video we'll be talking about granulatus
inflammation this is a high topic for
USM step one stay tuned till the end
granulous inflammation is characterized
by the formation of
granuloma so granuloma is basically
aggregate of immune cells primarily
macras which basically is surrounded by
lymp
lymphocytes now these granuloma forms
because they want to the immune system
want to contain the bacteria which are
hard to eliminate so immune system
doesn't allow these bacteria to spread
throughout the organ they want to
confine this bacteria into a particular
volume so that is how granuloma forms
these are basically macres which are
trying to uh prevent these infections
from spreading so obviously we
understood macres are the key drivers of
this granuloma formation so let us try
to understand the process so the first
step is the initial encounter where the
maccrage is trying to engulf the
pathogen in general terms maccrage would
engulf the pathogen and Destroy them but
in some cases for example microbacterium
tuberculosis destroying these pathogens
is difficult sometimes these bacteria
Clump together and overwhelm the macras
so in those conditions macras gets
activated and these activated macras
lead to formation of the
granuloma now when they are activated
there are certain cellular and
morphological changes occur within these
particular
macras and activated macras ensure that
they basically prevent or confine these
Invaders into a restricted location
there are two types of macras broadly
but M1 macras are pro-inflammatory and
they have Central role in defense
against pathogen and M2 macrophases are
anti-inflammatory in
nature now in this particular granuloma
formation several activated macras cells
are recruited which prevents the
bacteria to spread further eventually
these macras secrete pro-inflammatory
cyto kindes such as il1 il6 Etc which
attracts th1 subtype of t- helper cells
and these all these cells Clump together
form these granuloma inside the
granuloma there are certain changes in
the maccrage structure for example
several macras fused to form a giant
cell which appears as multinucleated
cells there are also activated
microphases there are also lymphocytes
found in this granuloma structure now
let us understand the overall histology
in bit more details so here one can see
the lymphocytes in the periphery of a
grotus uh formation one can can see
epitheloid altered maccrage cells and
one can also see giant cells which has
several nucle which are basically fused
maccrage
cells now if now there are several types
of giant cells for example uh langan's
giant cell is one of the most common
type of giant cell and this is commonly
associated with tuberculosis infection
so in this case what is the pathological
significance
this langhans giant cell which exactly
look like a horseshoe shap
region this is basically a pathological
Hallmark of tuberculosis infection so
from a lung biopsy or from other tissue
biopsy if somebody can notice this sort
of formation one can really suspect that
there is an invasion of
tuberculosis there are other uh
instances where the infective organism
is not really a bacteria it's basically
some sort of foreign material which is
not present in the body let's say some
tal powder or some crystals that might
lead to this sort of granuloma formation
that is known as foreign body giant cell
formation in this case there are also
multinucleated cells which are the giant
cells but the nucle nucleus are arranged
randomly it's not like the Langan cell
where there is a characteristic
peripheral Arrangement here the
arrangement is quite random and
basically they formed due to foreign
body exposure like tal sutures
Etc now let us try to appreciate the
morphology of the giant cells for
example in langhan cells nucleus are
peripherally organized in foreign body
giant cells the nucleas are hazly
organized there are also situations
which are known as ton gine cells there
are tumor Associated giant cells
associated with anaplastic Cancers or
hodkin lymphomas for example red
Stenberg giant cell is associated with
Hotchkins Lymphoma then there is
osteoclastic giant cell all of these are
collectively known as tumor Associated
giant
cells now since you are more familiar
with the hystopathological features now
let us look at our original section here
you can see the core of these granuloma
actually com comprises of macrophases
and M multinucleated giant cell
surrounding the core there are several
other immune cells such as mostly
lymphocytes there could be also
fiberblast which are associated with
tissue
regeneration now let us talk about the
common features of granuloma formation
there could there there could be
basically agents or pathogens which can
lead to granuloma formation this include
sarcosis tuberculosis leprosy brucelosis
syphilis and and also uh
lymphogranuloma Venum which is basically
a sexually transmitted disease all these
disease might lead to granuloma
formation at this point it's important
to note that granuloma formation and
granulatus infection is very different
from the chronic granulatus disease or
cgd because cgd is basically an inherent
disorder in this case a gene is mutated
for due to which the neutrophils are
unable to destroy the pathogen so neutr
involvement is heavily uh associated
with this particular disease neutrophil
can kill any bacteria with the help of
reactive oxygen species burst or
oxidative burst and these reactive
oxygen species are generated by an
enzyme called nadph oxidase which is
encoded by the gene so obviously there
is a mutation in this Gene which lead to
a reduced production of Ross that is why
even if the pathogens are engulfed they
are not destroyed destroyed this could
be EXL or even autosomal as well now
generally Whenever there is a pathogen
engulfment the oxygen is converted into
Super oxide radical with the help of
nadph oxidase then Super oxide dismutase
convert it into H2O2 eventually myop
peroxidase convert into HCL radical and
these free radicals are actually
damaging to these pathogens they they
take part in elimination of these
pathogen it's important to note that
these free radical are also regenerated
inside the neutrophils via specific
pathway now how does Ros can damage any
protein or any bacteria so Ross can
alter the lipid composition it lead to
lipid
peroxidation thereby damaging the
membrane it can also damage or
structurally alter the proteins it can
lead to DNA damage and problems in DNA
repair this is how it kills the bacteria
in case of cgd these aspects are
abrogated because nadph oxidase which is
supposed to produce Ross is inactive and
that is why even if the neutrophil is
engulfing it it cannot degrade it that
is why they form clumps which is again a
granuloma formation but in this case
neutrophils are the key molecules which
are associated with these granuloma
formation along with macras gentic cells
Etc now patients that are at high risk
of infection by Catalyst I these
patients which has cgd they are at very
high risk of infection by stus oras or
aspergilus
Etc now the symptoms include enhanced
infection by stfas orus fungal
infections like candida aspergilus Etc
symptoms might include persistent fever
pneumonia skin infection GI issues ETC
now there are many complications that
could be associated with cgd this might
be um some of these are obstructive
uropathy uh hepat spom Al and also
inflammatory bile disease but these are
secondary so now we can understand
clearly that granula granulatus
infection and granuloma formation or cgd
is very different so I hope this video
was useful and informative if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up you
can support our Channel using super
tanks see you in next
video
that